it is my privilege to introduce dr sreem
ahmadi today uh who is our guest um
and and dr muhammadi is a pulmonary
critical care physician who i actually
got to meet when he was working at
hillsboro medical center uh and also
at the time was a demy student
and since then you know he has moved to
the cleveland clinic where he's a
practicing staff physician in pulmonary
medicine but he's also the enterprise
medical director for clinical
informatics there and
i'm really excited to hear about
some of the innovations that they have
done
at the cleveland clinic and some of
those some of those things that sri has
been at the kind of forefront of um and
really i think uh the the take-home
message is yes it's perfectly possible
to do
uh a masters from demise and then be
really successful in the field of
informatics um uh after that and so with
with that it's my it's my pleasure to to
turn the floor to dr mahmadi for today's
research conference
thank you vishnu for the generous
introduction it's always a honor to
be invited back by your
training uh institution
um
i was very fortunate to have trained
under you and dr hersh and many other
faculty at the uh masters program at
ohsu so for that i'm ever grateful
um
and thank you for the thank you to the
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology for uh
you know inviting me uh to this uh
uh talk uh as i said it's always a honor
and today what i really wanted to uh
kind of talk about is the uh
the applications of behavioral economics
uh in
uh in in in the design of uh the emrs uh
uh architecture uh and uh the lessons
from the behavioral economics
uh before i uh really um dwell into the
um
just a second
before i really dwell into the um into
sort of the objectives of the talk uh i
just wanted to sort of uh uh
sort of state the uh rezandiatra for the
emr right and the reason for its
existence
uh as clinicians and clinical
informaticists i think we all can sort
of agree
that
the emr
one of the main reasons for its
existence or its justification is uh to
improve healthcare quality
um and in that context uh i think there
are two domains of healthcare quality
that are very pertinent to our
discussion um the one is effectiveness
and the other is efficiency and
effectiveness being basically delivering
evidence-based care
and efficiency
basically meaning reducing the unit cost
of care while you're delivering
effective care
and
obviously many tactics in the emr to
achieve healthcare quality
but i think
two things that have received constant
attention or the clinical decision
support which traditionally comes in two
flavors an intrusive form in a
non-intrusive form
um obviously it's like preaching to the
choir here inclusive wallets obviously
will pop up alerts triggers the ultimate
aim of changing behavior
whereas people have already also sort of
looked at non-intrusive decision support
a good example of that is displaying
narrative knowledge
uh and hoping for a change in behavior
and a good example for that is
displaying price data to providers to
see if
reduction in the
costs can be achieved
this was actually one of my topics of
interest while i was at ohsu and we
ended up performing a systematic review
trying to look at this question does
physician
price display does it uh influence
healthcare quality and we restricted our
search to you know randomized control
trials and we found around
uh eight
or nine randomized control trials
uh very diverse group of trials across
outpatient inpatient uh various settings
what we really found was that there was
no consistent relationship between price
display and
quality in other words
displaying the unit cost of a medication
or a test really doesn't uh have a
in a consistent relationship
in other words healthcare quality is
really not a function of price awareness
at least for the physicians uh aspect of
it there were some studies which showed
some response
but again they were restricted to four
medications or a few tests and things
like that so this really uh served as a
motivation uh uh uh for for me to sort
of understanding how can we change the
behavior of physicians or providers in a
very busy environment
in a very cognitively overburdened
environment
and how can we sort of start looking at
affecting change and of course intrusive
decision support as we know uh
you know it's uh really the downside is
in again preaching to the choir along
desensitization loss of autonomy and
whatnot um
so in it it is in this background that i
want to actually
introduce
a few things about nudges you know these
are the objectives of my talk
uh what are nudges and what is the nudge
theory
exactly in the context of the emr
and
you know discuss the present evidence
you know
supporting its use as a tactic to to
achieve healthcare quality
um
and uh you know how can nudge theory
inspite design help
interaction and our experience our own
experience here in the cleveland clinic
so what is nudge uh i think uh most of
you are already familiar with it but i
want to go ahead and formally define it
for the benefit here
not is an intentional redesign of the
choice architecture
without any restriction
of choices and no tangible rewards to
the end user
in other words it's a very intentional
redesign almost like a paternalistic
sort of intervention where you sort of
redesign the choice architecture but you
really don't infringe on the autonomy of
the end user but at the same time there
are no economic incentives as well and
the objective is to change the behavior
of the end user
and it's a byproduct of the behavioral
school of economics two good examples
for nudge applications in real life
one is the opt-out mechanism of
opt-out choices for organ donation in
driver's
license applications where
you know default is check-in your
default selected for organ transplant
and you have to make efforts to say to
remove that selection and say i'm not an
organ transplant candidate
um an organ donation candidate and the
other uh nudge application in day-to-day
life was a good example was arranging a
healthy food on the aisles of grocery
stores at the level of the eye and the
idea was that it was an intentional
choice architecture design designed to
uptake your buying of healthy foods as
opposed to
you know nutritionally less valuable
foods um and
it's it's it's really considered a
byproduct of the rational school of
economics from the university of chicago
uh again in direct contrast to another
school of economics known as the
rational school of economics
in which
you know end users have the time to sit
down and analyze the trade-offs and and
make a choice that is the most uh
rational uh in terms of economic gain or
other gains
they are not really mutually exclusive
schools of thought i think one looks at
behavioral school of economics and tries
to answer the question
how do human beings make choices when
they are cognitively burdened and how do
they make choices when they have a lot
of choices
on their plate uh and other when they
have a lot of choices and and none of
them really and they can't really tell
in in the limited span of time what
exactly they want to pick up so that's
exactly what behavioral school of
economics tries to understand and for
folks interested in in much more
detailed explanation about the nudge
theory uh the links were provided here
but uh you know it was the subject of
the 2017 nobel prize awarded to
dr richard taller tyler and his group
and university of pennsylvania uh school
of medicine as even a medicine nudge
unit that works very closely with their
clinical informatics folks to
sort of affect changes in the emr
um and again a little bit more on the
background you know they're really based
on the intersection of three
well-defined scientific disciplines that
we're very uh comfortable with uh one is
physician computer interaction uh you
know um you know how do physicians
interact with computers you know number
of clicks
visible information and whatnot and the
other school is the evidence-based
medicine which of course has been there
for uh for a long time and has a rich
tradition and the idea is to increase
the uptake of effective and efficient
interventions in the emr and of course
the behavioral economics that we talked
about
exclusively focusing on physicians or
providers
burdened with cognitive
information or cognitive overload and
less amount of time available to make
those decisions
um two nudges uh really come to
my mind when talking about emr design
and i would like to go ahead and name
them as default and sorting nudges and i
think you can see these examples now in
the literature folks are trying to frame
different types of nudges and i think
you'll start seeing these terms very
commonly used default and sorting nudges
a default nudge is a
is a architecture design in which you
either introduce a default or you remove
a default from an existing order within
an order set so that's the sort of the
default nudge
sorting nudge is an intentional redesign
of the choices from top to bottom and
the idea is to present the most
effective and most efficient choice for
a given disease or a state in the top
two or three choices and let the others
gravitate to the bottom
and
folks might probably have already
observed that when a computer is asked
to arrange multiple choices
most of the times it takes the route of
alphabetical listing and
they might not necessarily be the most
effective and efficient choices but
that's how computers arrange things when
when when you really don't
when you leave it to the computer so
sorting nuts tries to stay away from
that and tries to intentionally
rearrange the choices
um i've used some
sketches some user interface sketches
for a hypothetical emr just to drive the
point home
for example a default nudge intervention
can be used to improve
you know generic prescription rates and
it's a good example of efficiency trying
to drive down the unit cost of
healthcare
in this example the provider is
searching for
vibramicine which is a brand name for
generic doxycycline and
cost is around five times the cost of
doxycycline and
what happens when you type in vibromycin
in this
example is that uh there are two choices
one is the doxycycline which is generic
arranged on the top
uh and the other is vibramicin which is
the brand name and is arranged as the
lower choice
just a second
sorry and here in this chart in this
example you see that
the first choice is a genetic choice and
the idea is that the provider would pick
this doxycycline and move forward
however we are not restricting the
autonomy of the uh
end user uh if the end user feels that
vibramicin which is the brand name
doxycycline is indeed useful
and then he or she might still pick up
the choice and dispense it as written
and here you can see the dispensers
written being pre-selected this is a
good example of
using a sorting
as well as a default nudge and trying to
improve the
usage of
generic toxic cycling
this is a very busy slide
let me
to make sense out of this uh just a
second
um
i think it's the visibility is still
okay
so this is a very busy slide and let me
just try to make some sense out of this
and again this is a a collection of the
recent
literature trying to
show the importance of introducing or
removing the default
selections in the order sets so in the
first row
we have a very good example
here in this
example it's a natural experiment done
an institution
using
the emr
specifically the post
transfusion
order sets in this example what's
happening is when folks receive a
platelet transfusion because their
platelet count is low
the end users are not following it up
with a post-transfusion platelet
estimation in other words you need to
know how much your platelet count has
improved or not improved so that you
could make some
clinically useful decisions
in this intervention what the authors
have done is they have observed that
the platelet transfusion order was not
pre-selected it was there in the order
set but it was not pre-selected and now
only around 10 percent of platelet
transfusions ended up getting a
post-transfusion platelet estimation
they went ahead and introduced a default
selection to that and suddenly the
the uptake of post transfusion platelet
jumped to almost 50 percent and then
they went ahead and removed that default
selection and then suddenly drop down to
back to native uh uh um
prevalence of almost five percent or
something like that so it's a definitely
not a randomized control trial but
almost uh you know a fantastic natural
uh experiment done within the emr
in this example the second example in
the first row
the admission order sets for this
institution
had a default selection of telemetry
which is a very expensive resource
and
the baseline prevalence of telemetry
utilization was almost 75 percent and
again that can lead to a lot of
unintended consequences like
availability of bets
inefficient patient transfers from the
ed and whatnot what they have done in
this ex study was just remove the
default selection of telemetry from the
general medicine admission order sets
and what they found was that the
utilization of telemetry came down from
a peak of 75 percent to almost 50
percent and they did present some safety
data as well which which i did not
include in this slide that they did not
really see an increase in adverse
patient safety events
um likewise many other examples here i
think this example the third example
malhotra from jamia i think is very
similar to the vibramison example that
we talked about
where
the dispensers written
was sort of manipulated in such a way
that
the generic prescription rates jumped
from a baseline of 40
to almost 96 percent
um the fourth example is a very
interesting example this was uh the
baseline was actually a pre-selected
order for 20
opioid pills
during the pre-opioid crisis era when
there was a lot of attention on
improving patient satisfaction in terms
of pain and it was pre-selected and this
was the mean amount of pills dispensed
in the ed almost 4 000
and when they realized that this was
what was contributing the default of 20
pills that was pre-selected in the ed
discharge order set when they removed it
you can see almost a 50 reduction in the
amount of opioid pills prescribed in
this community ed
likewise the
fifth example is a very commonly uh
cited example where the default for red
blood cell transfusion is a commonly uh
transfused resource when the default was
changed to one unit in the emr which is
of course evidence-based what they have
realized is the number of red blood cell
transfusions have reduced from 32 000 to
27 000 and again a good array of
examples um
stating the power of introducing or even
removing default and as i said like you
know
not just
introducing defaults but sometimes
removing them is also needed as a
quality intervention and we talked about
the telemetry example
now we all talked about a lot of
observational studies and a lot of
natural experiments within the emr i
just wanted to uh spend a few minutes on
this slide because i think this is very
very elegantly done uh randomized
control trial just using the emr as an
infrastructure
and emr was used as the vehicle for
randomization the setting was community
radiation oncology practice
almost 10 community radiation oncology
practice
practices
belonging to the university of
pennsylvania health system
and the idea was to clamp down on daily
imaging
in palliative radiotherapy patients in
other words patients receiving
radiotherapy as a means of improving
their pain but not necessarily treating
their cancer
they really don't need daily images
to monitor the progress or to monitor
the history natural history of their
cancer
um so they wanted to really climb down
on this and what they did was they
employed a wedged
rct design using the
using the
community practices as the unit of
randomization as well as the emr as the
vehicle of randomization
what they realized is they introduced an
order known as no daily imaging needed
and they pre-selected the order
and they employed a fetch design
obviously the the default was removed
when they were
back to control and it was introduced
when they were back to the intervention
group on on an average overall the
system saw the baseline prevalence of
ineffective inefficient daily images
uh a daily image test thing come down
from a you know peak of almost 70
percent to almost uh you know 50 percent
a reasonable
effect size uh you know
25 percent absolute reduction and and
you know good example
so we talked about the default measure
so just want to spend a little bit uh
time with the sorting nudge and this is
directly in spite from our example here
at the cleveland clinic what we've used
how we use the sorting nudge here to to
solve
a problem in copd care and the setting
is basically care of copd patients and
copd obviously is uh you know chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease uh you
know it's exist punctuated by repeated
flare-ups in some people
and they require admission to general
adult medicine units
and uh we all know the power
of a well-curated order set in the care
of such a complex disease
and of course we you know have uh used a
copd flare-up or an exacerbation order
set
and the preliminary design the status
quo design was a very well done um
order set having all the
right interventions
uh helping the providers serve up
serve up a nice
function here the antibiotics the
steroids antibiotics and steroids being
the two most important interventions
needed to effectively take care of a
copd flare up and as you can see many
choices right antibiotics we have
amoxicillin amoxicillin clavel in it we
have bacterium doxy in the steroids the
same problem you have methylprednisolone
which is in parenteral iv form of
steroid and prednisone which is an oral
form of steroid
so
what we have done in this was to help
the baseline function of this order set
really helped people take care of copd
flare but what we realized is the most
commonly used antibiotic was ended up
being amoxicillin and the most commonly
used uh asteroid in the care of these
patients ended up being methyl
prednisone which is intravenous and
definitely more costlier than prednisone
and more recently evidence has you know
accumulated to a point where people have
shown that prednisone is as good as
methyl prednisone and doxycycline
obviously has become one of the top
choices across the world for flare up of
treatment or flare-up of patients
so we wanted to sort of change the
behavior of our ordering folks too
and we ended up actually
employing a sorting nudge to uh you know
do this without uh you know without any
intrusive technician support as our
first goal ended up arranging
doxycycline to the top here uh violating
the alphabetical order and we also ended
up putting in prednisone as the top
choice
um
and uh
you know we
you know we already started seeing some
very good changes
and
at the end of
one year when we looked back we realized
that
while we solved this problem we ended up
having opening up a different set of
problems and that problem was that our
drd codes were higher for iatrogenic
effects of steroids like hyperkalemia
which would actually sort of be
not a good thing in the era of
value-based payments you know we want
our
patients to
not have any hydrogenic complications
from our interventions
so again
this problem served as a motivation for
going ahead and somewhat elegantly
redesigning this order set by combining
both the power of sorting and default
measures where we defaulted the
prednisone to a oral dose obviously and
we defaulted the duration to seven days
again this is based on an excellent
feedback from subject matter experts who
actually you know distilled the
literature to convince us that you know
duration of seven days is is is by far
a defined duration of prednisone is by
far the most effective intervention
rather than just prednisone as you know
most of our rounding physicians are you
know obviously burdened and once a
prednisone
choice is made
theoretically that prednisone could be
going on forever until the patient is in
the hospital so that probably was one of
the reasons for our nitrogenic issues
like hypokalemia and things like that so
we went ahead and defaulted the
prednisone to seven days again based on
evidence-based uh feedback and and data
and we defaulted the doxycycle into
seven days and and most of the times the
flare up should have calmed down by
enough and if it's really not coming
down then it's really not a copd
flare-up in the first place so again
we were able to solve the problem
an audit after six months showed that
our incidence of hydrogenic hyper
hypokalemia has come down which is
in fact a direct consequence of
prednisone usage
another example
here
the use case was the icu
and lab stewardship committee wanted to
clamp down on ineffective and
inefficient usage of blood cultures so
the background here is that whenever
folks have a fever right
you know blood cultures remain the
primary uh uh
primary uh methods of investigating the
cause of fever
but uh um
but uh in a in a situation where you
type in blood culture into the emr the
baseline in our in our health system
and our health system you know
especially the central campus thousand
beds and and across both states of ohio
and florida ended up counting on 5000
bits you can just imagine the travels of
a physician when trying to investigate
the fever in a large health system when
you type in blood culture you get three
choices blood culture blood culture
times one and blood culture times two
and i know and and myself being a
practicing clinician i never really
realized the difference between these
three things and
obviously if i'm inundated with these
choices i would just go ahead and you
know
most likely to choose blood culture and
move on because i'm not really sure what
exactly times one and times two mean in
comparison to the first choice so the
lab stewardship committee started
noticing a lot of blood cultures being
ordered that did not meet the volume
minimum required volume so these subject
matter experts came to us and said that
look in an adult if you really need to
investigate a fever
there are data to show that uh the more
volume you get the more likely we can
give you a pathogen but of course more
doesn't mean you know exaggerating the
patient but you know there's
it requires two aerobic bottles and two
anaerobic bottles
and
they wanted us to introduce a intrusive
decision support to solve this problem
and we really looked at this problem and
said you know really this looks like a
fantastic opportunity for sorting and
default mergers
but
pediatrics came on and said that you
know we really need the blood culture
times one because this is exactly what
we do in our kids because we can't
really you know employ four uh bottles
of blood from our kids because they end
up having hydrogenic anemia
so definitely become very clear that
blood culture by itself has no meaning
so we decided to remove blood culture
from our emr order sets
and rearrange the um
order in such a way that blood cultures
time still shows up fast and blood
cultures times one shows up
second and this was a sorting luxury
design
and we knew that this was a temporary
solution because we didn't want our
pediatric patients to be subjected to
blood culture strengths too so we took
some time and ended up actually
combining both the sorting and default
not just to solve this problem once for
all
in with some help from
some ordered display rules where we use
the patient's age greater than or equal
to 18 years and the only order that
would show up is blood cultures thanks
to and we're going to make it easy for
our physician colleagues by defaulting
them the choices to both blood cultures
times two in other words they would know
exactly what they mean
by blood cultures times two when they
are ordering this test
is really a is two sets one one set of
aerobic and anaerobic repeated twice
that's really what it means
and no more confusion so
the adults really were very happy with
this change
when the pediatrics there were some
nuances
anyone between 13 and 17 years
obviously
apparently had to be treated as adults
by pediatric infectious disease folks so
what we did here was we still preserved
the autonomy of a blood culture single
drop for those rare patients who might
be at risk for hydrogenic anemia but
again defaulted and
do another choice for this 13 to 17
years of age
group patients but if the practitioners
wanted to do a single draw as you can
see here in this example they still have
the choice here and they can still go
ahead and it's not a default choice you
have to think about it and change it
whereas in adults you wouldn't never get
any choice whatsoever the only blood
culture that you have is blood cultures
times two
and for less than 13 years of age again
we sort of used the
um choice architecture redesigned to
default it to
only one that is blood culture times one
and we specifically named it a pediatric
bottle to drive the point home that this
is a
completely different workflow and
different volume
with this what we really were able to
accomplish was a very thoughtful
approach to order set redesign and avoid
unnecessary intrusive decision support
and make it a much more evidence-based
approach to design so we ended up
proposing the nudge manifesto within our
own internal
information systems governance
you know this is what we hold ourselves
accountable to whenever we look at our
order sets and our clinical decision
support
um you know we hold a semi-annual review
of order sets based on our clinical
institutes
and we certainly use this manifesto
loosely termed as the manifesto to
really drive almost like a checklist to
sort of drive our engineering choices
and clinical decision support obviously
is sort of the you know
the next alternative if things like this
don't work and this is what we will
learn from our experience we avoid a
routine alphabetical listing of orders
because it will lead to unintended
consequences the first choice will
always be the most one used
we always list oral medications
especially if we have the backing up of
the subject matter experts before
parental choices
[Music]
and then we always list the you know the
most effective and efficient choice
first even though it might be you know
relatively invasive
um this is something that we have talked
a lot about using a preferential font
and color for our choice and we tried
working with commercial uh vendors
unfortunately we did not get any uh help
um and uh
um you know we
again we don't have much uh
institutional experience with this but
our idea was to use a preferential font
and a color for the intended choices to
drive the point of
to drive the point home that this is
what we recommend to use in this
situation but again we haven't been able
to execute it in in
we are talking to our commercial uh
health and electronic vendors to vendor
to to sort of
you know get this
in the works um
and of course whenever there is a
medication always or a lab uh try to
default it to the dose and duration and
i think the most common example that all
of us know now is the importance of
daily lab testing like complete debt
count and basic metabolic panel being
defaulted to you know three days or a
day depending on your institutions
sensitivities
and of course not only introducing this
defaults but removing them keeping a
keen eye for these defaults and removing
them is as important as introducing them
in the first place so you know clearly
we sort of you know frame this on our
experience and started utilizing this as
a routine
in a
checklist
so you know so what i would like to
conclude is that if you have a a
nudge-inspired
approach to
governance and user interface design
i think there is a lot to be achieved
here i think uh governments have
improved organ donation rates uh people
have reduced accident rates on busy
roads using nudging spike design so i
think there is a lot of scope for that
in the emr i think at the end of the day
it still preserves the physician's
autonomy as opposed to a clinical
decision support tool you know one
author called the intrusive decision
support a shelf as opposed to a nudge i
think that's uh clearly i think the case
um and i think for us what attracted us
the most was the
[Music]
minimal demands on uh education and
implementation costs
um
you know decision clinical decision
support uh you know obviously
is it's a little bit more intensive uh
build and dissemination of uh change and
all those things but i i think here is
the idea is that you know you're sort of
betting on the
cognitively
uh
you know busy human being to sort of
click the defaults and keep moving on so
it's got to be very carefully used of
course it cannot be abused
um
and i think um you know if this are such
a good idea you know one thing that is
not really out there in the literature
except for a recent randomized control
trial i did not include that here uh
coming out from i think masjen and the
and the in the masjid and boston where
they're using a randomized trial
technique to study the effects of nudges
but if they are really so good then
really we need to start assessing them
right and i think this is where uh
you know we're starting to do this um in
our enterprise as well
you know i'm sure that folks are aware
of this paper that came out in nhm a
couple of years ago about rapid cycle
randomized testing where the emr is used
as a vehicle of randomization and the
patients can be randomized at the level
of your interventions can be randomized
at the level of patients
on
mrn or nursing unit here in the
cleveland clinic we use the nursing unit
we've already done two rapid cycle
randomizations
um and we've used that to sort of you
know
buttress our changes or to move on to
other changes but uh
the beauty of
the emr and i think that's one of the
most unintended advantages of the mod
that i've ever seen is use that as a
vehicle of
randomization but i don't think the
vendors are yet there to help us
you know do this off their shelf
versions currently we use our own list
to program in such a way that we can use
the art versus even
mrn as a means of assigning this
interventions um assigning this back of
the envelope studies if we might use the
term but i think some of these
interventions need to go through such uh
sort of
semi-rigorous evaluations and you know
there's already a rich body of
literature about using rapid cycle uh
randomized testing for these things
and just uh sort of closing the talk
with uh you know good which is a you
know hindi word it's uh you know it's a
south asian but uh in other words uh uh
describing low uh uh uh resource
innovation right i mean the idea is like
people can innovate and you know
innovation is not really the issue
the issue is how much resources do you
need to innovate right that's the key
here and i think
nudges could not just in the emr could
be looked at up as
you know once
some sort of a low
resource intervention one that is
readily in the hands of the information
governance councils within your within
our institutions to make these changes
without going through extensive
buy-in and extensive education and
post-implementation audits and things
like that but again that's obviously not
the only way to solve problems but i
think they are being underutilized and i
think um it's a it's time has come for
us to take a good look at these
behavioral economics interventions if
other industries and
nations and governments have improved
using improved some of their outcomes
using not just why not as uh in the
electronic health record which is you
know again the perfect example of a lot
of choices but with limited time and
these are some of the take-home messages
that you know that i felt were pertinent
to our journey here
with that i conclude the talk and uh
again thank you so much for inviting me
and my apologies if uh
if the slides are not visible as good as
i used a pdf so
thank you
thanks free
and and you know this is a really
interesting talk and i'd like to kind of
open the floor up for questions actually
i'd like to start with a couple of
questions if you don't mind uh
the first question i have is you know
you touched a little bit on the
unintended consequences
of these kinds of interventions you know
on the surface
it you know it looks really great and
opportunistic did you have a
conversation with your team about
potential unintended consequences were
there things that you were worried about
apart from the usual resistance to
change and you know kind of physician
push back
yes i think that's the um i think that's
a very good question vishnu and i think
a
good example is the telemetry thing
right when you're removing the telemetry
um
default from the admission order set one
wonders whether uh one wonders whether a
patient who would have benefited from
telemetry is now not uh you know getting
the telemetry and could end up having
some adverse events
um and i think that is the reason why i
touched upon the rapid cycle randomized
testing um i think however simple this
intervention might be this also needs to
go through the audit the problem with
the current landscape is that even
intrusive interventions don't go through
any audits and you just
you know put in a
an intrusive wallet and
we just look at some basic metrics like
how many of them are accepting it how
many of them are blowing away from it
going through it but we really don't
look uh take a good look at least
at least in our place we don't really
take a good look at the outcomes like
you know if you're really talking about
an intrusive wallet to
increase um
um
like awareness of acute kidney injury
are you looking at outcomes such as
number of dialysis in your units or
number of uh
acute kidney injury diagnosis in your in
your unit that got subjected to this
intrusive wallet
um so i think um without such a rigorous
or semi-rigorous i would call it
evaluation it's hard to answer one is
always worried about those unintended
consequences but at the same time one
could also argue that if you're
inundating every admission with the
telemetry order set what about that
patient who needs telemetry can't get
the telemetry bed
so i think using that rapid cycle
randomization at the end of three months
define a list of pragmatic outcomes and
take a look at those outcomes and if
they're reasonable
continue with the change and if not then
pull back the change
that's very true um my second question
is that you know one of the really
interesting things about this form of
kind of nudge interventions that it's
almost at the end user level it's almost
subliminal right they don't
they don't quite know that they're
making the choice but they make the
better choice so then if we're actually
you know kind of implanting subliminal
messages into clinical end users based
on our redesign of ehr interfaces
is there a risk that we'll introduce our
own biases into this
you know into this decision-making
process and do you have a process for
de-biasing before you actually
um you know go through with intervention
no very very well said uh vishnu i think
uh again again um that's very well
captured that clearly
um one who has the loudest voice or one
who has the most influential voice in
the group can drive and lead the group
towards group think and unintended
biases um i can uh i think the one thing
that uh we've used as a as a safeguard
to prevent those biases from creeping in
was to have honest discussions with the
subject matter experts like for example
the copd flareup set the decisions to
default them or the decisions to default
the dose in the duration were clearly
driven on
on subject matrix but review of
literature and sharing of that
literature with us
or sometimes it's very operational uh
like for example during the covic
pandemic a lot of folks were getting
daily labs for ddimer and troponin
because in the initial stages of the
pandemic people were worried about
corona virus cardiomyopathy very
unintended consequences with that was
that we were running out of lab reagents
it was almost a crisis-like situation
where the lab stewardship committee had
to make midnight phone calls to start
doing something to prevent daily
troponins and daily uh d-dimers
and obviously part of the issue was the
uh fact that d-damage can be ordered and
left alone and leads to unintended
consequences of daily d-dimer so
whether we liked it or not we sort of
took a paralystic attitude we had to
because that was a crisis mode and and
defaulted the d-dimer to once every 72
hours
but yes
yes
yes you can
this can lead to an internet
consequences as any other intervention
in
healthcare information technology and i
think it should be done in a group-based
consensus and with the blessings of the
subject matter experts who know uh
who have much more nuanced con
idea about their disease and their care
i think there were a couple of
questions in the chat
would smart default be a better solution
smart meaning a different default for
different patients
um
i i think that would be a fantastic way
if we get there but that we're talking
about precision medicine in one form uh
right we're really talking about the
let's say for example you're talking
about the copd patient with a high iso
fuel count and you're basically
defaulting them to a different dose of
steroids as opposed to you know just
giving an example but i don't know if
our current uh
emrs are
in that
level of uh um thing but i i i think
that's a great uh great uh thought
um but we are not aware of any use case
and we'd be willing to explore if there
is a use case to to do the smart
defaults
also sorry i'll add one quick thing
which is a lot of our cds is manually
curated right now
you know and and it's the informations
and the folks you know who have to kind
of curate and update and maintain and
call those those rule sets um you know
unless we can automate some kind of a
cds solution that kind of smartly kind
of adjusts this uh running it out of a
rule-based environment you know you have
to you're just creating a lot of work
to keep all those things current um it
can get very complicated very time
intensive very quickly
i think you're very well said vishnu and
i think one one what we have done is we
have used the u2 example where the
governance is kind of takes care of some
of this uh
you know ineffective cds where they have
a small working group that meets prior
to the bigger group but you're right
without uh minutes it can get very
onerous and very labarius right off the
bat
and uh
i think
the folk says it's not juggered anymore
uh it's a noun or a verb but i i don't
know the answer uh and
actually i'm not a native speaker of
hindi uh uh so i i think it's sort of a
noun i guess uh it is a noun in a way it
is it should be a noun
they asked the chat question was whether
god is a noun or a verb i think i'm
probably favoring now
thanks presenting for the question
any other questions for first three guys
so chris says you know how can we
influence vendors i think that's a
loaded question chris
do you want to take that
well um i just want to say i'm happy to
come online for a minute and say it
verbally you know i read your take-home
messages about the vendors should make
it easier for us to do this and you know
you share the challenges you had with
fonts and colors and i really kind of
wonder
how what is the critical mass of us as
you know purchasers of this system that
would have to come together to
kind of agree on a font and color to
kind of you know so the idea of getting
them to let us customize it to whatever
we think is best i could see where that
is is challenging potentially for them
but the idea of
is there enough agreement about the
science of what a preferred font and
color could be that we could just ask
them to provide that as a single choice
across the board for all of their
customers and maybe that's a smaller
ask potentially
no i think um i think for sure uh
for sure there has to be some uniform
agreement and whatnot
um and i think there are has been some
literature about uh breaking uh um the
uh continuity of uh
let's say the alphabet like you know if
you write a as in a full a or a i think
i can try to share my screen just a
second if i can
but i don't know if rigorous studies
have been done in the health uh
uh
health uh information technology aspect
um i think i don't know if folks are
able to see this uh um but uh you know
are you able to see the screen
no it's still on your take home messages
okay
let me see
are you able to see something now
i see the
webex
your webex
yeah okay
sharing your meeting window just one
second sorry yes
okay now i got it
are you seeing sans for gettyka
yes yes
yeah so this was a very interesting
study that came out from australia where
they looked at a better font how humans
comprehend
reading from electronic screens and one
of the ideas behind this font was that
for critical uh
text where you really want them to
really focus on this the idea was that
you would break the continuity between
the actual uh you know you'd introduce
this small breaks in between uh
um
in between the actual font and one of
the things that we postulated during our
systematic review when we looked at
physicians provided price display and
not being able to
effectively translate that knowledge
into intervention one of the reasons we
came we sort of postulated was that
folks probably read and comprehend
differently from electronic screens as
opposed to paper screens and there's
been extensive literature in computer
science on this topic and i'm definitely
not a computer scientist but i came
across a couple of norwegian studies
where they randomized uh school children
to
um
paper uh materials and
other schoolchildren to
paper white electronic materials like
kindle screen and they looked at their
school living examination scores
and after controlling for patients
parents socioeconomic status and whatnot
they found clearly that the paper
materials uh the group that was
randomized to paper materials performed
better and they termed it as screen
inferiority the fact that you can't
really learn and
you learn in a different mechanisms
from the electronic screen as opposed to
a paper
so that was the driving point for that
and we sort of explored that with our
commercial vendor but at your point
there is no uniform agreement so you
know it's hard to sort of get that level
of customization but i think this is a
good opportunity for some of uh
some of the studies to happen on that
front and sort of
start intelligently using our fonts and
whatnot
another way to look at this make the
preferred order the easiest most
efficient choice
and then christine said this is helpful
as i deal with our governance teams to
shift from default alphabetical listings
and yeah i mean this it's still
surprising to see how many people use
alphabet as the listing choice
when clearly
you know the drug companies seem to
start every drug with the letter z
so really i think it's it's interesting
that you know the the and and and
and maybe chris can kind of this
can and i hate to put chris in the spot
but maybe as a library interest i mean
how
how antiquated is the idea of
alphabetical sorts
in a in a computerized universe
and why do we still cling to it
um
when clearly there are other options
available
as
a species
yeah no i mean i i don't think i can
really speak to how alphabetical sort is
hanging on in terms of you know the ehr
environment but i will say in terms of
browsing browsing functions versus
searching functions in terms of how
users
are using the tools we have to help them
find other kinds of information the
really the browse has kind of almost
been imploded by the search the the only
issue really is honestly that i would
actually ask this group you know to kind
of think about is
search is also being kind of taken over
by the fact of you have to know what
you're looking for or everybody is now
so reliant on the autofill from searches
so that when you essentially it's almost
like a browse because when you start to
type the first letter of your search
it most of the systems that people are
accustomed to nowadays start to offer
you all kinds of things to search that
maybe weren't your item and if you
weren't that comfortable with it you
weren't that comfortable with that drug
name you weren't that comfortable with
that spelling you weren't that
comfortable
with it you're going to be offered
things that you then have to spend your
mental bandwidth discriminating out that
you didn't intend ever to begin with and
so i actually think that's the
newer kind of
challenge with search versus browse that
we're starting to see as everybody
expects auto fill in
but then auto fill in adds to the mental
complexity of making sure you did the
right thing now that helps if you're a
horrible speller but they'll offer you
sometimes actually the thing that you
didn't want or didn't know
yeah now that's very interesting
i did not realize that it adds pressure
to
whether you're asking the right question
or not so
and looks like we should just put in
something in the chat that
that's probably
true we are not able to get consensus on
really big ticket items in the ehr you
know as a community and you know the
thought of you know this the the
informatics community the clinical
community coming together to get
consensus over things like fonts is
really you know both interesting and
challenging at the same time
i think three as you mentioned you know
if you can show that things like you
know we've always known that the way
that the the
interface is designed really affects
efficiency really affects you know
clinical outcomes for some reason to
some extent right if you don't see the
value of the lab that's critical you're
not going to be able to fix it
and so you know if you can make the case
for for these things that other
industries have known well you know the
the appropriate placement of of the
right kind of fonts building upright
kind of fonts at the right you know
instances
it really does make a difference i
wonder when we'll be in a position to be
sophisticated enough to do something
like that for ehr
yeah i think time has come for real-life
simulation but uh you know obviously hsu
is a business has been a great place for
uh studying eye-tracking behaviors and i
think some of the commercial vendors
need to go through the same rigorous uh
evaluation and publish them in the open
uh peer-reviewed domain
srimina asked how long are nudges do
organizational culture patient
preference
and prior training finally take over
physician behavior
that's a very
sorry
issue with the mute buttons that's a
fantastic example so i think i can speak
with the power of n is equal to one uh
because that's the longest nudge we had
of almost like two years now
which is the copd admission and the data
are holding on like you know prednisone
still continues to be the preferred
steroid and doxycycline still continues
to be the preferred antibiotic and we
have seen a sustained reduction in
hypokalemia
probably moving away from
methylprednisolone is probably our most
dedicated guess
so i would say with the uh
with the caveat that that's the longest
nudge we have had in in production
i think they can last well because here
you really you're to dr mohan's point
you're really not uh it's a subliminal
intervention you're really not
infringing on the autonomy um
so it's very likely for the end user to
have been you know
felt you know trampled upon in other
words uh so
and i think this is one of those things
again this is a very good ethical debate
and i think there are some good debates
out there on youtube and tedx about
these things in in nudge interventions
whether you're being petrolistic without
sort of you know
really telling the end user that you're
doing this right so
um but
but i think um some of this is
probably long-lasting
and mean actually followed up with a
question that she still sees the merit
in education for longer lasting
behaviors
um
but again
you know a new group of physicians come
in a new group of clinicians exit you
know groups of clinicians exit new
groups come in so sometimes some of that
is uh kind of a tough one uh and a good
example of that is uh uh i think uh
diffusion of innovations you know they
take a lot of time like you know to
really get into
into into real-time practice so
education sometimes can be a
a a tough one but definitely it is one
of the most valued interventions i
completely agree with meenakshi that at
the end of the day that is what it is
you know you got to really convince and
change the uh the physician and give
them evidence to sort of support their
behavior but again this is not a
one-size-fits-all intervention i think
this is one of the tools in the toolbox
and i said often in turns and med
students learn standardized orders from
order sets that's very true
that's true
i want to be mindful of everyone's time
we're almost up against the half hour i
want to thank sri so much for coming
this is a really interesting
intervention it's really interesting
conversation to have
um and i think you know um
certainly something that the ci fellows
and i will be talking about a little bit
in the future also because these are
also relatively easy to implement as
long as you pick the right the right
interventions
um so thanks again dr dr muhammadi for
coming and
with that i think we can
we can end this session
thank you vishnu and it's always a
pleasure to come back to uh ohsu's
informatics program and thanks for all
the great education over the years
don't worry welcome home yeah bye all
right
thank you thank you everyone for joining